Speaker 1: The nuclear question is increasingly
being asked, I guess, and it's not necessarily
being answered at this time in the Russian
invasion of Ukraine, but as time goes forward
and as the takeover of Ukraine does not go
nearly as quickly or nearly as smoothly as
reports indicate, Vladimir Putin expected
it to go.
The concern grows that maybe Vladimir Putin
would bring out the nuclear weapons now when
we talk about nuclear weapons.
This can mean a lot of different things, and
I think some people imagine, you know, Hiroshima,
Nagasaki.
That's not actually what's being considered
here based on what Russia has, and we're going
to talk about that.
But that's actually not necessarily a good
thing.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
An interesting article from defense one concern
rising that Putin could use nuclear weapons
Russian escalate to de-escalate doctrine suggests
Putin is thinking the unthinkable.
And Patrick Tucker, who's the technology editor,
writes the world should take Russia's escalating
nuclear threats very seriously.
Senior intel officials told lawmakers Tuesday,
noting they haven't yet seen clear indications
that Putin would respond to the military setbacks
in Ukraine with nukes.
Putin sparked alarm among nuclear watchers
last month when he ordered the nuclear forces
put on a special regime of combat duty.
And that speaking to lawmakers on Tuesday,
Avril Haines, the director of the Office of
the Director for National Intelligence, said
the move was mostly signaling to keep Naito
from intervening.
However, not everyone is so convinced that
these are these are merely empty nuclear threats.
And then the question is what do you what
does it mean?
What would it mean if Russia actually nuked
Ukraine?
Well, there's a lot of discussion of that,
and there's an article on Heritage Dawg that,
yes, it's the Heritage Foundation.
It's an accurate piece.
Russia's small nukes are a big problem, and
it explains Russia has a 10 to one advantage
over the U.S. in non-strategic low yield nuclear
weapons what are sometimes called tactical
or battlefield nukes.
And this is actually an area of concern.
There are some who are hearing about this
and saying, Well, it's good that Russia doesn't
actually have or would would not use the big
nukes here.
But the way in which it could be a strategic
disadvantage is because Russia has those battlefield
or tactical nukes, and Naito has a much smaller
supply of those.
Putin knows Naito can't really respond with
those particular types of nukes.
And this, the concern is, could actually be
a signal to Putin.
If I do this, they're not going to drop like
the big boy on Russia.
So therefore, it might be an opportunity to
use these types of nuclear weapons, tactical
nuclear weapons.
And there's a lot of a lot of a lot that you
can read about these.
These are again sometimes called
no